[ __ ] well it got a little hard on top
but it's all wet you're still talking
about the toast
[Music]
welcome to wagon baked with Kevin Andy
the show that takes cooking and makes it
dandy I'm keV and I'm Andy what are we
cooking today we are making french toast
today yeah but this is not your
grandmother's French too but I'm not
going to eat it no no this is better
this is fresh so beautiful your Bibles
worth my grandmother practically plays
it is on par with your grandmother's
don't wrench don't threaten memories in
the Charles you know when you're
finished with your fruity pebbles and
your and it's right down at the end
there and you take your pinkies we'll
put them out and you drink that stuff
yeah
that is the milk we're using to make our
french toast did your grandmother ever
do it that way back is it really oh my
god you took something perfect made it
better and you're absolutely right [ __ ]
my grandma let me tell you what's in it
dry cereal milk melted butter packed
light brown sugar Texas toast
two egg powdered sugar and basis Europe
we're going to take our ball okay cereal
and you've done this before I'm sure you
poured milk up cereal I got I've made so
much cereal in my life and here's your
milk use all of this all of it
and smell experience go back vintage Oh
Oh heaven
20 minutes later it's soaking up all
because we want it to be soggy you want
to basically everything that's in the
cereal is soaked into the milk and we're
going to strain it out so this is a
strainer [ __ ] oh my god
and so we're straining it right yes
can't we defeat the cereal I know we
want to have it to be a vanilla peach or
look at that the body good
not dead low all right so we're
straining this out and we're left with
colorful sweet milk the way it comes out
of God's own cow now we're going to be
some eggs into it already went cracked
so now we're into the world of regular
French Catholic all right you want to be
whipping them with a good so I'm going
to prepare our casserole dish by putting
some melted butter
and the brown sugar brown sugar in my
melted butter and we're just going to
lay this down like a nice layer oh it
should look like Oprah treasurer
don't lick them off of anyone elses
finger so I'm getting this all down to a
layer okay I get sticky it's pretty
mm-hmm like sand castles ma'am you look
like that little boy on the beach and
jaws that cop would have been a lot more
invested if his kid got English
remember how I bet yeah there was or is
like high fixed on that each two more
let's get that aside why because we're
now going to put our toast into the
casserole oh so you don't soak the toast
no this is all cutting edge technology
we're all a grid now kids so we want to
get four pieces into the bottom of this
dish well you need to go to those grow
up own to your hands to me let me do it
I'll use my method see I do should evil
and press it down and come on behave
Texas toast
I like this build with people again you
can also you look at that realloc I
build this church and like every good
God crush it then we take about half of
that stuff just to half just have
because we're going to do two layers
okay and let's and we're pouring this on
try to evenly pour it on top we can
spread it around you can use your
fingers the back of the floor and I add
a thing my grandmother would do this to
this bread make sure don't don't no
really it makes the eggs so gentle
alright so we pour about half on yes I'm
going to use your volumetric estimation
skills but we just do as much as the
pencils Wow
you learn so much that's about two cups
so we're putting them about come
whoo Lee is erotic now check your Mary's
neck and chest oh yeah we got a whole
cup to do now we're going to take some
extra cereal over there because the
layer goes in between a little layer
sprinkled through it's like a joyous
confetti of cereal and then we do
another layer of this that's correct
keep your technique is any better than
mine I'm such it can you touch it well
it's going to go in the oven then get
cooked so is that what happens so you're
allowed to touch the food because once
it gets close all the girls side you
don't wash your hand right no now we're
going to cover this with foil voila as
you foil handy that's going to go in the
oven at 350 degrees for 40 minutes 40
minutes - it better taste like you can
even care for death okay beautifully
done sir so it goes in the oven 40
minutes should we awkwardly stare it at
one another for 40 minutes while we wait
for this to cook no we do the bad thing
gomen another okay I put on my black
c-3po gloves because this gracious me
because we're going to take something
out of the oven open up the oven like a
state talk marshmallow look is that
where you're like I feel like I'm on
duster woo now it's pretty do you think
we're done don't answer yet yeah of
course we're done Oh ready to go
no Sara we're going to take a little
sugar sprinkle that on top and make
we're going to make a brulee you won't
remote that's not too heavy that's
pretty good on that one your leads on a
fat guy not too heavy on the sugar where
your uncle is maple syrup we're going to
take our friendly neighborhood blowtorch
yeah oh my god it kids put on your
safety goggles on that on a little bit
get that going and now I want you to
kind of flame that down melt the sugar
and then caramelize it
[Music]
see how it's melting and rounding I
think that now you're starting to light
everything else those are not raisin so
let's stop okay I got that let's serve
it up plate it as they say in the
business which one do you want I would
say this one has the least amount of
spit in it
so enjoy oh thank you sir I'm gonna take
this one's got a little extra on the
side
in fact guy looking out for yourself
when you got the syrup and we can pour
that over top for the traditional french
toast rich go Therese
time to taste this and see if we did it
right [ __ ] well it got a little hard on
top but it's all wet you're still
talking about to test this takes it from
french toast and once you put in cereals
of America and you did it as a favor to
me so it's Mentos oh my god Oh [ __ ]
that is like the [ __ ] greatest thing
I've ever done in my life like I've made
movies I've had a child
[ __ ] compared to this that's like
[ __ ] weird God's normal I take a bar
I mean all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can tell you something right now
right here at Luke Craig kitchen heaven
on earth like honestly I only want to go
home anymore how my family going to
compare to this nothing in life is going
to be as good as this what's this year
I want punky wood to go [ __ ] run we
just drop the mic and quit the show
right now because what's going to be
better than this lookit better than your
grandmother's okay this is amazing my
grandma what hack you want to see us
make other things in the lootcrate
kitchen my dear and lootcrate kitchen
lootcrate compasses and you got to go
out there in the social media and tag us
on twitter or facebook and instagram
make sure you hashtag loot crate let us
know what you'd like to see us cook man
but trust me I only need your suggestion
this shit's brilliant thanks for hanging
out here on wake-and-bake with Kevin
Andy I'm keV I'm Andy Bon Appetit my
friends [ __ ] another club
[Music]
you